What we'd like to represent is that the cost of congestion increases in a
quadratic manner as the loads on the
links continue to increase. Ultimately becoming increasingly expensive
as link utilization approaches one. Solving the
optimization problem, however, is much easier if we
use a piecewise linear cost function. We
can define utilization as the amount of traffic
on the link divided by the capacity and
our objective might be to minimize the sum of
this piecewise linear cost function over all the links
in the network. Unfortunately, solving this optimization is still
NP-complete, which means that there is no efficient algorithm
to find the optimal setting of link weights, even
for simple objective functions. The implications of this are
that we have to resort to searching through a
large set of combinations of link weight settings
to ultimately find a good setting. So clearly searching
through all the link weights is suboptimal. But
the graphs turn out to be small enough in
practice such that this approach is still reasonably
effective. In practice, we also have other operational realities
to worry about. For example, minimizing the number of
changes to the network. Often just changing one or
two link weights is enough to achieve a good
traffic load balance solution. Whatever solution we come up
with must be resistant to failure and it should
be robust to measurement noise. We also want to limit
the frequency of changes that we make to the
network. This completes our overview of intradomain routing. And
now we will take a look at interdomain routing.
Intradomain routing and traffic engineering concerns traffic flow within
a single domain, such as an ISP, a campus network,
or a data center. In contrast, interdomain routing, and interdomain traffic
engineering, concerns routing that ocurs between domains, something that we
looked at before in the context of the Borda Gateway Protocol.